so uh
what's a black swan event wants to field
that question yeah i'll jump i'll jump
into this one so
one of the the uh the title of the black
swan event is most often attributed to
nicholas nasim toleb
now he is a he's both an economist he's
been he's a professor he's he's he's an
author he's kind of one of those
autophages he's accomplished many things
um but he um
he wrote a book called the black swan
and the idea of a black swan event is
something it is a large event a large
catastrophic or a large event of of very
effective proportions whatever that
either a could not have been predicted
or b
if it would have been predicted it
wouldn't have happened and therefore
would never have been noticed and so he
when he opens up uh i think it's when he
opens up his book the black swan he's
using the example of
911. so if a person
had if anybody in the airports had said
it's strange that these people have
these items and just simply taken them
then there would have been no 911.
interesting right
and no one would have heard they
wouldn't have been promoted they
wouldn't have been made into generals or
heroes it was just like all of these
little things had to happen in a row
where it ended up in a catastrophe that
no one predicted it's a cascading
failure yeah right i'm not going to use
the word cascading failure because i'm
not going to be specific on that one but
you might be correct in the sense of
that one where well there's that story
of um it's a jose melendez perez was the
was the one tsa agent um who had been i
think he was um he's a puerto rican uh
served in i think vietnam and he was the
one who stopped um oh it was muhammad
al-qatani who was you know supposedly
the 20th hijacker um in from coming
through in florida and because he just
and i always remember the story because
it was like
he just seemed he just says he seemed
off to me right this guy got put in
secondary screening and
you know because he didn't he wasn't
able to answer the questions when you
come in you know hey where are you going
how long you staying when he flying back
didn't have good answers to questions
gets put into secondary screening and
then jose melendez paris goes to see him
and says
look this this guy's got military
training i can see he's got like a
military bearing to him and you know
like you kind of know if you've been in
the military like hey this guy's got you
know and something seems off his story
seems off he doesn't have a return
ticket and then they pulled him aside
and they said hey man this these this
guy's saudi you got to be you know you
got to be pc you got to be careful and
emelianes perez says i don't care i this
guy
everything that i'm supposed to do says
this guy shouldn't be allowed into the
united states so i'm going to send him
home and he did send him home and he was
supposed to be the muscle man for
um for united 93 so that's why united 93
only had four hijackers as opposed to
the others that had five and he was
supposed to be one that was doing crowd
control for the the um the passengers as
the as the other guys flew and then
what they what melinda's paris didn't
know
was that waiting to pick up muhammad
al-qattani in
the you know the parking lot of the
airport in florida was muhammad atta who
was the lead the lead hijacker you know
because one guy just
did what he was supposed to do just did
his job so here's why i asked from the
new york post palantir buys 50 million
dollars worth of gold bars to counter
black swan event oh boy yeah uh so
what does palantir do
so palantir is i mean they're they're
like a database of databases if that
makes sense right so they are they are a
software which allows for database
integration
and
you know think of you know and it i know
this from you know the intel community
using it and that's where i was able to
get my fingers on on the volunteer
system but you could you really use it
for any big any large data set
i know this is starting wall street's
starting to use it more pharmaceutical
companies are starting to use it more
any these massive data sets and it's
basically like
you know
you think of any like um
online database where you're going
through files and then things are linked
to each other well this is it's
multimedia and one thing can pop up to
another it's all tied together you can
do aggregation i mean they are
what you know and and a palantir of
course is from lord of the rings and
it's it's the seer it's kind of like he
and you've got a little you know that's
ian's palantir right there right there
it is there
is it's a crystal ball right the idea is
has a it
like yeah it's uh lord of the rings
facetime yeah so there you go all right
yeah yeah it's it's what it's what who
was it was it mary or pippin they they
saw it and they grabbed it and they said
yep so uh the colorado based company
purchased 50.7 million dollars worth of
100 ounce gold bars sometime in august
palantir said in a short note buried in
its 93-page second quarter earnings
report last week
they say uh the company previously
announced that it would accept bitcoin
as a form of payment although it hasn't
said that it's invested in any bitcoin
yet unlike some other companies
including elon musk's electric car firm
tesla
uh
what what what is what are they well in
palantir is uh it's peter thiel oh i
know i know but i'm saying i don't know
what what's the
what's the black swan event that they're
seeing they have all this data they're
the seer stone and they're like we think
we need 50 million dollars in 100 ounce
gold bars yeah i saw a meme where they
were
saying and they're not like the guys on
tv saying you know buy gold
right william devane when when sauron is
buying gold you have to wonder right
what's going on what does sauron know
yeah
so i don't know what do you guys think
is it uh it's economic they're they're
hedging against economic inflation is
that all you think that's like they're
they're they know it's coming so dude
one it's going to be magnitude but
that's not a black swan event one
conversation
70 bucks that would be black one
conversation sort of a meta conversation
i've been having a few people
you know offline um lately is if you
just look like if you take the last five
years worth of events and you kind of
put them all together but you look at
them
from
you know go through the mental exercise
of going 20 years in the future and then
looking back
these last five years just the amount of
upheaval
and the quickness and speed with which
events have transpired it sort of feels
like the preface to
something right it almost feels like
you're reading you know this okay this
is the back story of how we which led us
up to the event it kind of feels like
you're on a roller coaster and it's that
the clinks are going slower and slower
right
are you sitting in the front or in the
back of the roller coaster always the
front man i'm in the front hundred
percent you got a hundred percent yeah
behind you yeah i wanna know i wanna
know yeah i wanna watch let's see what's
good
yeah yeah i'm not a big roller coaster
person though it's kind of boring peter
thiel is heavily invested in like
bitcoin uh marketplaces and stuff so but
so so what is this and you're saying you
think that
it's going to be an economic
shock to the system there's going to be
a magnitude of of cost inflation like
times 10. that's what magnitudes are no
we're already saying it we're already
seeing it we're going to see
things that cost six dollars cost 60.
it's going to be absolutely that would
be insane i don't know it's gonna be
guys do you guys agree
well i mean that that makes sense as to
why they were because i mean from what
you're saying that's why gold right
because it's it's yes there's a black
swan event but it'll be tied to
economics it'll be and obviously you
would buy gold as a hedge against fiat
so the idea that and that it now it may
also be though that they're they're not
quite sold on crypto yet and they're
thinking that look you know we kind of
went through the pandemic and
and you know there were you know there
were times where crypto seemed like it
was people were using it as a store of
value but other times where it was
seemed like it was crashing along with
the stock market because there's a lot
of speculation in crypto as well and so
um it's not an awkward crypto twitter by
the way you know it's all the crypto
bros out there um but it i'm just
talking about how it went last year and
so you've got to think that that from
volunteers perspective they want to go
at the more traditional store of value
that people have run to in a crisis and
that's gold what what would be a black
metals what would be a black swan event
that would hit the economy in
such a way that they would need 50
million dollars of gold bars they could
print 120 trillion dollars tomorrow
right but is that a black swan event it
would turn out it would create a black
swan does that make sense no no you make
a good point would the printing of 100
trillion dollars be the cause of the
black swan of the event or would it be
the event itself good call because was
911 was it the response to the buildings
coming down that was the real black swan
event like the war or was it the actual
building how do you define was it the
fact well maybe i think in that one
would be was the black swan event at uh
the thing that contributed to what we
call the black swan event of 911 was the
towers coming down but the things that
contributed to that are all of the
subsequent or the all the preceding
events that no one predicted no one
thought anyone was going to
hijack a personnel carrier well and
crucially so maybe the formation of the
feminism
i'm pretty sure they had uh
uh they had done drills specifically uh
mentioning this it's been a long time
since i've read you know a lot of the
news but i think the new i think i i
just mean to say that it was a failure
on the part of the government and it's
it's kind of like when i mean certainly
hijackings had taken place yeah yeah but
it's when biden says we planned for
every contingency we know they didn't no
you did right yeah and when they said
like oh who i think it was like i don't
know who was condoleezza rice at the
time like who could have predicted they
would do this it's like the us did
not specifically but they knew that
planes could be used as weapons look at
this last weekend in afghanistan that
was a black swan event because we're
like okay well we i mean anybody who's
been there knows has some expectation
that as the as america recedes
somebody's gonna fill that void and if
it's not the afghan military the afghan
government
at the time it's going to be somebody
else and who's that going to be it's
obviously going to be the taliban we
just did not expect it the black swan
event was that they precipitated on
across the country so quickly
and so that's kind of the multiple
layers of failures of of ma of the
relationships with the local people not
on the individual level but on the state
level and how do we how do do are we
looking at this social investment in the
country and taking it seriously
no
so i i read a bit about afghanistan and
what uh i can't remember i don't know
who wrote this they said that the u.s
pulled air support and as soon as that
happened that's the centerpiece of
american military strategy so they give
the afghan security forces you know
these air capabilities but then biden's
like we're pulling support and we're out
well
there was actually an interesting uh and
it kind of ties into what you're saying
there is an interesting angle to that
because it was something along the lines
of and i don't want to get this wrong
but the idea was that we were
maintaining
the afghan air force and they didn't
have the capacity to there i am using
buzzers capacity
the capacity to maintain their own air
force so when we pulled our contractors
and essentially our mechanics for their
air force rather than having you know
it's like
you know
it's like you teach a man to fish right
you know um that the minute we pulled
those mechanics out they didn't have an
air force anymore is that because in the
20-year training that we were training
militant like militants but not
engineers
well we were training the the arm i mean
i won't you know put word your mouth but
we were training armed forces what was
it that wasn't
mechanics though i i was not i i was i
was in ranger battalion i was not in
charge of understanding the relationship
why didn't you train them better
come on man because
please please it's very clear they never
taught me how to fly everything we've
seen is forceful it's obvious
it's not invited it's not true
you have discovered what the department
of state thinks yes exactly it's not our
policies it's the guy on the ground he's
the guy and the grounds are too long
yeah yeah exactly yeah
so but here's my question here's my
question his gas cannot be properly
fitted because he's not gonna be saved
here's my question to you forest yeah
could we have withdrawn in such a way
that afghanistan would not have fallen
to the taliban in three days
yeah yeah absolutely
and that problem would have started
maybe 10 years ago because we we didn't
plan for when did we start planning to
pull out of afghanistan legitimately
like how long was it just an eventually
thing we'll do it right well we're going
to leave we have to leave we have to
figure out the terms on which we're
going to leave maybe
us
we we who are seen as the powers that be
the generals are like well we wouldn't
we're only going to willing to pull out
when it looks good when it looks good
for my political career
yeah that do you think that's not a
thing like absolutely no no no no well
that's what that's what uh you saw that
thing from matt zeller where he was on
msnbc and he said that he told them over
and over again planned for this but they
were more concerned about looking bad
than actually solving you know planning
for the problem and now they look bad
because of it yeah plus you got guys who
and i'm sure you know this dynamic well
it's hey we can't pull out now i got a
deployment coming up i just finished my
training we're all ready to go we're
about to do this you know i'm about to
make rank so this last time this is my
my chance to be in the c in the hot seat
on deployment i'm not going to skip my
deployment i'm going no yeah no one
wants to be a tabbed ranger who went
overseas who never got to go overseas
never never has to go home and visit his
family and run into his uncle who's
annoying as possible who was in the
national guard and he's got three
deployments under his head
no that's 100 true but it's that
mentality that drives a lot of this
decision-making too i think it has
influence on it i don't i wouldn't
consider it a root cause i think it has
i think i think it's a symptom not a
cause
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time